a good makeup artist can transform even
the most
recognizable actor into a weird
wonderful
or terrifying alien and make them pretty
much
unrecognizable in the process here's
what these movie aliens look like
without their makeup
lee pace has appeared in a whole bunch
of movies and tv shows over the years
but arguably
his most high profile role is ronan the
accuser
the alien villain of the 2014 marvel
film guardians of the galaxy
in the comics ronan is part of the blue
skinned alien species known as the cree
so makeup artists elizabeth yanny jorju
and david white
had to paint pace's whole body blue and
almost entirely shroud his face in black
tar
while promoting the film pace told the
youtube channel screenslam that he
actually
loved wearing his extensive makeup
because it serves as a
mask for the character he explained i
move my face
in a different way but what's great
about that too is that it's not the way
the character looks it's the way he
wants to look he's got blue skin but on
top of that
he's painted this fearsome mask because
that's how he wants to present himself
to the world
yanni giorgio and white also designed
the look for other extraterrestrial
characters in the film
which earned them an oscar nomination
for best makeup and hair styling in
2015.
as for pace he went on to play ronin
again in 2019's captain marvel
for going the black face paint since the
movie takes place before guardians
and features a less radicalized version
of the character
french actress maiwen labesco known
anonymously as maiwen
portrayed the tall and mysterious alien
opera singer diva plava laguna in 1997's
the fifth element
in a rare interview regarding her
extraterrestrial role in the movie
maiwan explained how the fifth element's
french writer director luke pason who
was engaged to her at the time
offered her the part of diva my when
initially passed however saying
oh thank you but if i love you i want to
show you my love that is
pure so i don't want to work with you
vessel ended up hiring a german model to
play diva but she didn't show up to her
makeup test and so my when stepped in to
play the part
my when also revealed that applying the
prosthetics needed to play diva took
three hours every day the team led by
lois burwell applied makeup around
mywen's head
before they glued diva's giant
prosthetic dome onto her own
they then gave my wen stilt and the
dress and
since my wind was so tall in her stilts
she required a special chair
and her own crew to help her eat and
drink
new zealand-born actor jermaine clement
is best known for playing comedic roles
in movies and tv shows such as what we
do in the shadows and flight of the
concords
but he also played a terrifying alien
villain in the 2012 film men in black 3
for which he wore an absolute
ton of prosthetics and makeup and it
took eight hours
so before you even start a work day
you've already had
like what most people think of it as a
as a work day
luckily by the end of the shoot the
makeup team had managed to get that time
down just a little but then they
they gradually got it down to four hours
now we can do it in three hours
legendary makeup artist rick baker who
designed the aliens for men in black
three and its two predecessors
brought forest to life and even made him
scarier than intended in 2012 baker told
digital trends
in the script i got originally he was a
biker but they described him as dennis
hopper from easy rider
i said you know what i think he should
be intimidating like charles manson or
1960s hell's angel president sony barger
i did these designs and kind of
reinvented what i thought he should be
actress model and dancer sophia botella
played the alien warrior jayla in 2016
star trek beyond
her first role that involved prosthetic
makeup while promoting the film boutella
explained to screenslam why she enjoyed
the long makeup process saying
the meditation aspect of it is like
getting into character
you actually take this time sometime you
get on set and you have
very little time i've never done
prosthetics before i like
that second skin i like what it brought
to me it's like as soon as i had it on
you feel in character joel harlow the
movie's makeup designer
explained to inverse in 2017 why
applying makeup to botella
took longer than doing the same to idris
elba who played the film similarly
inhuman looking villain crawl
he said it's deceptively elaborate with
lots of intricate dissections
sofia botella wore a forehead that came
down her cheeks and black design
markings that went all the way down to
her chin
the mouth nose and chin are sofia
otherwise
everything else is all a prosthetic the
time it took
was worth it in the end though because
harlow and fellow makeup artist richard
alonso
both received an oscar nomination for
their work on star trek beyond
british actor and comedian simon pegg
portrayed the slimy alien junk dealer
anker plot in 2015 star wars episode vii
the force awakens
in a 2016 interview with nerdist the
movie's creature supervisor neil scanlon
explained that while they applied
prosthetics to peg during the makeup
process
they also got a little help from the vfx
department he said
i think they did a little bit of cg
enhancement on the inside of the mouth
as well
to give him a slightly wider gape in his
mouth than what you could do in real
life
obviously it would have just been
simon's mouth otherwise even though a
little cgi was used to bring ankar plot
to life
it was nowhere near the amount used for
lupita nyong'o's maz kanata
or andy circus's supreme leader snoke
which were full-blown motion capture
performances
for plut though this successful blend of
cgi and practical effects
helped scamlin and the film's special
effects team earn themselves an academy
award nomination
sadly pegg himself didn't find the suit
all that comfortable
and i had this big rubber like silicone
gauntlets on which were my fingers
and uh when i took them off i could pour
the sweat out
at least you didn't have to wear it for
long australian actor ben mendelsohn has
played
countless villains throughout his long
career but his turn as the alien telos
in 2019's captain marvel
is one of the few roles for which he
actually wore prosthetics and makeup
although he gets to spend a little time
out of makeup in the movie taylor's true
appearance is that of a scrub
a race of green shape-shifting aliens
who are frequently found stirring up
trouble in the marvel universe
to taylor's credit at least he and his
cohorts are revealed to be refugees from
the kree empire halfway through the
events of captain marvel
so it's quite literally not all bad to
throw audiences off that particular
twist
legacy fx supervisor shane mahan made
the film's
skrulls look as intimidating as he could
landing on an appearance similar to that
of their comic book counterparts
when asked about the length of the
makeup process mendelssohn told
entertainment weekly that
in total it only took a couple of hours
when asked if the makeup team managed to
quicken the process at
all mendelson replied they have what do
i do
i sit there no they have they're awesome
it's a couple of hours
it's not that big a deal you know
mendelssohn ended up back in the makeup
chair once more for spider-man far from
home
and will likely don his prosthetics
again as the mcu grows
ever bigger and more cosmic especially
with the upcoming secret invasion series
looming over the horizon
it's a good thing he doesn't seem to
mind scottish stuntman
ray park famously wore a whole heap of
makeup when he portrayed the acrobatic
sith lord darth maul in 1999's
star wars episode 1 the phantom menace
the film's principal makeup artist paul
engelin spoke about maul's devilish look
in a 1999 issue of makeup artist
magazine
he explained the red i used was actually
a water-based aqua color that would
fade but it was quite easy to reapply by
sponging on
the black was real tattoo color which i
had to paint on
it's kind of elasticized so would tend
to peel
rather than run i sponged it on with a
fairly heavily saturated alcohol-based
sponge and
a lot of black pigment even with all of
the action scenes shot out there
it worked in an interview with sci-fi
wire in 2019 park revealed he was
initially unsure about maul's look
explaining
when they were doing me up i just
thought i looked silly you know
my big nose and my weird teeth and then
my blue eyes
and i just felt like a big panda you
know but once the contact lenses were in
and people were staring at me on set it
was like
wow park reprised his royal for a cameo
in 2018
solo a star wars story and provided
motion capture for the character in
the phantom apprentice an episode of the
animated series star wars the clone wars
josh brolin may have donned his motion
capture suit to play the alien villain
thanos in the marvel cinematic universe
but he wasn't actually the first actor
to play the role
in fact american actor and stunt man
damien poitier underwent a round of
prosthetics to portray the mad titan in
a mid-credits stinger at the end of
2012's the avengers
flash forward to 2014 when poitier
explained to the geeks with wives
podcast how he discovered which
character he would play in the avengers
the actor said i found out when i was in
the makeup chair what i was doing
they kept it super quiet because they
didn't want to put any spoilers out
so they kept it super quiet what i was
doing and i didn't find out until they
were casting my face to do the sculpt
although boitie sadly wasn't destined to
play thanos again
he did play hero merc 1 in 2016's
captain america civil war so
that's something at least in 2018 the
costume and creature design powerhouse
iron head studio
led by jose fernandez shared a
behind-the-scenes photo on their
instagram of poitiers wearing the thanos
makeup and prosthetics
as the caption details although thanos
ended up getting a digital sheen for the
film
and eventually became fully digitally
rendered in avengers infinity war jose
still has a soft spot for this practical
makeup design
while the practical thanos makeup was
done away with for later marvel movies
iron head did go on to design costumes
for captain america civil war
as well as a number of other high
profile movies and tv shows including
aquaman and the mandalorian australian
actress elizabeth debicki has starred in
a number of high-profile movies and tv
shows throughout her career but her turn
as the alien queen aisha in 2017's
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 was easily
the most makeup heavy of them all
requiring her to be painted gold from
head to toe while promoting the film
vicki spoke to comicbook.com about
putting on the makeup
she recalled they built a sort of car
wash there was
a lot of paint and a lot of sitting
around and drying
it's quite an intimate process the
film's makeup department head john blake
also spoke to makeup artist magazine
about giving aisha's species the
sovereign their gold look
going into detail about the trouble they
had trying to land on a good color he
explained
there's a lot of gold makeup out there
but some of it doesn't really have a
metallic gleam while others have the
metallic gleam but can look
very textury and crusty so it was just a
matter of mixing batch after batch of
different materials before i could come
up with a gold that had the right amount
of softness and metallic gleam to it
in the end blake and the makeup team
succeeded in giving the sovereign a
bright and visually
arresting gold look one that made them
one of the most
memorable aspects of the entire movie
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one